hey remember when China was bad
according to Donald Trump China was
taking advantage of us
China was killing us on trade deals
China China China deserve to be tariffed
and taxed and sanctioned and all of that
stuff they must be punished for taking
our jobs and we're gonna change the
geopolitics around China and start
winning again because we never used to
win we never we used to but we aren't
winning anymore or something remember
Trump's obsession during the campaign
with China
remember this let's say China China
China China China China China China
China China China
[Applause]
you go over to China China China China
China China China China China you take
China China China I love them China
China China China China I have to have
my China's so all of a sudden Donald
Trump wants to help China get jobs back
and when I read the headline I thought
there's this must be a fake headline
there's no way that Trump is now saying
let me help China create jobs and of
course like most headlines about Donald
Trump it's true and we've now found out
that not only is the headline true it
coincides with news of a 500 million
dollar contribution from China to a
Trump length project in Indonesia from
which Trump and his family will make
money and this goes back to American
sanctions of a Chinese company called
ZTE which was fined for selling
illegally to Iran and North Korea US
regulators found out that the company
didn't correct their violation so they
blocked American suppliers from selling
parts to ZTE and Trump says not winning
no he says the penalty is too harsh we
need to help the Chinese company get
more jobs tweeting the other day
President Xi of China and I are working
together to give massive Chinese phone
companies ZTE a way to get back into
business fast too many jobs in China
lost Commerce Department has been
instructed to get it done and just as
this very confusing and contradictory
position on Chinese jobs went public we
also learned that the Chinese government
is going to give a 500 million dollar
loan to a state-owned construction
company to build an Indonesian theme
park featuring none other than a series
of Trump branded golf courses and hotels
Trump is literally saying that a company
that was stealing the intellectual
property of American companies and was
sanctioned because of their sale of
product to Iran was punished too harshly
and we need to help recover Chinese jobs
it is difficult to put into words how
the coming together of these events the
Chinese government's
loan to an Indonesian Trump linked
resort and Trump's sudden desire to help
China create jobs represent the full and
total bamboozling of the American people
that is the Trump presidency because
this is so brazen that even the stalwart
conservative publication National Review
is reporting about this and as usual the
defenders say exactly what you would
expect them to say Trump has no
involvement in the operation of that
resort okay but he's aware it exists
Trump won't own the resort it's just
being branded Trump yes for which the
Trump organization receives money they
will say the loan has nothing to do with
Trump's position on Chinese Chinese jobs
maybe so but isn't it yet another one of
those disgusting swamp filling
coincidences and I want to go back for a
second to the sanctions part the
sanctions are meted out by the US
Department of Commerce Trump going on
Twitter and saying he's simply going to
interfere with the Department of
Commerce to change the punishment is
also a major threat to the integrity of
corporate law enforcement which is
effectively what this is so the
immediate questions which have been put
together by Public Citizen how does this
not violate the emoluments Clause aside
from the Chinese jobs element when did
Trump become aware of the anticipated
500 million dollar Chinese loan to the
Indonesian resort project have Trump and
the Chinese president discussed the loan
to the Indonesian resort project and has
it been discussed at any other
government level and in the end remember
Trump said there would be no new foreign
deals by his company during his
presidency that is another direct lie
which has been broken and then finally
let's go full circle back to the steel
dossier right the Trump Russia dossier
one of the things that the dossier says
is quote suggestion from source close to
Trump and mana fort that Republican
campaign team is happy to you had to
have Russia as a media bogeyman to mask
more extensive corrupt business ties to
China and other emerging countries is
this yet another element of the steel
dossier that is being proven true
certainly seems like it and Republicans
I'm ready I am ready for you two
come the party of law and order and the
Constitution and all that is good in the
world call this out call for an
investigation into this and that's at
least what a couple of reporters did
with Raj Shah yesterday today's program
is sponsored in part by fruit or the
tour is a social forecasting game where
players come together and compete with
each other to predict future events you
open up the game on your phone or web
browser you'll see a whole range of
forecasts covering topics across the
board politics sports so much more you
wager on predictions about real world
events using futures in game fake
currency and you earn more of this
currency every time you make a
prediction that comes true you can show
off your prediction skills to friends
improve your forecasting ability I'm
even on futur you can find my account by
clicking the link in the description if
you're watching this on YouTube and this
week on future I posed the question will
robert molars trump russia investigation
end during this year during 2018 what do
you think place your bets and you can
sign up now at fruit or calm and start
making your forecasts on political
topics and so many other topics it's
free and it's available on both Android
and iOS as well as on web browsers
that's fut you you are calm